because we are very happy to be joined
by 20 pounds mr. peter molyneux how you
doing sir good Thank You boomer and it's
you you have a copy of Goddess here we
actually do we have a copy of goddess
we're going to Trina we're to try and
play it and so when did you guys drop
into San Francisco yesterday and is it
is it a busy GDC as ever pretty busy
yeah sure I've just come from at all
where I was scheduled to talk about
going from mm in deep from indy tip
corporate to indy yeah you end up being
a talk about desks why is that well
sighs of desks standing desks no yeah uh
you know I could see the GDC you're
talkin I was going oh sure what we
should do now what my premise was I had
photos of all the desks I've ever had
okay from your liner days and Laura
premise was the Messier my desk the more
crazy and creative it is so I have them
my desk at the moment the most messiest
when was the cleanest desk you had that
was fable three okay it was potted plant
in the corner and a monitor and that was
it you know it was just beautiful you
know simplicity yeah they do this yeah
so you mean are you enjoying yourself
you've obviously had you know we've gone
from the days of both frog lion heads to
being sort of it's almost like attached
to Microsoft in terms of what they were
making like large big-budget games
obviously we're twenty two kinds you
guys have decided you've stepped back
into perhaps like smaller teams more
creative endeavors have you feeling a
better nevets Bennett well you know
here's the thing is that for me and this
is from this is just me for me when you
know when life is it as its most
dangerous and most risky and most
unpredictable I find that stimulates me
creatively and I think it stimulates a
team as well and you know as a small
indie company there's 20 of us and
sometimes it feels like we're paddling
this life raft with a big hole on the
side and now we're going to reach lamb
before we all sink and and die that's a
bit extreme and and and I find that's
when the ideas really come
when you when you can say to your team
that we're doing something that's going
to mean something to this industry
there's going to be a you know a
landmark and this is what I've been
saying is that if we truly believe we
can make something where it will make a
difference you have in the world and
then that is brilliant and that's hard
to do when you're part of a big
corporation where do you think it's
easier to be that more creative or more
innovative or more influential if you're
on a smaller team yeah well because
you're so much more nimble you know I
always think that big corporations like
super tankers you know it takes about it
takes about you know I want to turn it
certainly i think around but you know
it's like being in a little in a little
not about paddle boats head low a
peddler acting gain d I was gonna say
conch so I don't even know the conscious
is it on our oh thank god it's a good
I've been here too long Peter yeah my
Irish I persevered Irish weed Patty's
Day yesterday and I could barely speak
with Alec actually you you you must be
in touch and softer yesterday why would
I be in touch oh oh with empower to
think that my putting on a brave face
are you put it that way and I've been
celebrating all weekend since we won the
Six Nations so don't don't worry about
me whatsoever and if that cricket or it
sorry it's six nations cricket rugby oh
it's wrong not a sports man you're too
busy making video game and speaking on
Colbert sports but I had big computer
cakes too much time it takes to it I
could speak to you all day but first of
all I want to have a look honest
obviously uh you're saying and I think
actually do you have a one of those
dongles in your pocket or am where I do
yes tumbling around you guys waiting
selling stuff for like 20 minutes or
something LOL just agree that me needs
to be mindful well we have one back here
but it turned out to like not quite play
nice and so we're gonna give this one a
shot I got the cable back here so so
goddess this is if you guys released
curiosity yeah the M I phone app which
then sort of am bestowed upon the winner
a life-changing which is that he will be
the first I'm going to go God of gaga
coladas yeah this is we've heard of it
this game forever with is obviously
Kickstarter you guys are on Steam early
access as well and now we're looking at
the ipad version
yeah so just tell us like for people who
maybe have not heard of it or when they
were plagued our games and don't know
anything about populism yeah what is
goddess and what type of scale of game
is this okay now this is this is a good
game and and the whole reason that I
started this little company called
22cans was to reinvent what we all think
of God games because for me God games is
this ability for you as a player to play
in a world that gradually evolves around
what you're like is you know and you
know I could just see evil looking bad
driver like how always had the horns I
can work without our again and and but
it's more than that we what we've done
we've been working very hard to give you
a world which is infinitely moldable so
Jack is now just scrolling around with
his fingers this version is on the iPad
and when we release it it will be on the
ipad or mac on the pc and the iphone
will be doing something x version as
well I'm every version well done that's
that's good how many people buy that
they come of those places exactly cover
all the branch cause that's what are
there more and so the first thing is the
most simple thing that you do is mold
belong and the little people will
actually react so you can just see there
the what Jack's doing is moving his
finger he's tickling the land caressing
it he's making loved all rights this
type of video game a it's very gentle
and loving yeah and in doing that as he
does that your little people you only
start out with two of them will
interpret what you're doing and will
evolve around what that is so he's just
he's just molded the land and created
this something called a plot now if he
tapped someone in the houses that simple
it's just a one of these little people
come out and he will do what he wants to
do now guess the whole spirit of a good
game it's less about telling person a to
do thing be and is more about inspiring
the people because what you're doing by
inspiring your people is taking those
people
from the primitive age and if we go to
the timeline Andre we take them from the
primitive age all the way up to them
conquering space oh you're tracing the
entire history of humanity does your
that their relationship with you changed
throughout the game do they become a
loop more faithful less fierce like they
will change we have these things called
Commandments where you say you know I
think you should do this rather than
that and everybody's people is going to
be different that's the core of what the
game is but what is incredible about
this is as you play everybody who plays
good as is connected to everybody else
we're all sculpting on this giant planet
and we're all nurturing our own little
people on this giant pad and after
you've been playing for a few days you
will meet another god I'll gather player
and after you've been playing a few more
days the two of you will meet other
people until eventually you'll you'll
start realizing that it's not just you
it's not just your people you need to
trade you need to compete unito has even
go to war with other people out of the
human beings you're going to meet so so
what's the first what does that mean in
terms of does that mean that essentially
when the game launches that weeks and
months down the line it's essentially a
different type of game for the people
who have played it I don't yes indeed I
don't know I don't really know how this
is going to work out because we haven't
yet turned on meeting other gods that
it's going to happen in three weeks time
when we release unlimited access in
April yeah and that's already axid know
that lives beyond that beyond iOS in New
Zealand Denmark island you're just gone
for like weird island nations and I
guess your days will the all the
countries that don't play would not be
except i'm okay i'm new zealand and he's
worthy or bones have been a rock visit
yeah you're right it was for tigers time
so don't worry about huh that's right so
we're that's when we turn that on and
that's when it's going to be what's
going to be so fascinating is what
people do when
they meet each other and because when
they meet are they going to be
aggressive to each other are they going
to try and trade and be nice to each
other and we give we allow the
flexibility for either those things to
happen is that a daunting experience
that essentially the perhaps the the fun
or entertainment that somebody might
take out of the game is essentially out
of your hands because for instance if
people crafted these wonderful towns and
they've got their their populations and
whatnot and then somebody they meet it
introduces war to them and then kills
them off it yes how does I feel like I
needed you going to the dogs yeah I can
see you there or enjoy a challenge or
eat dog now what we do is you we've got
you've got something called home world
now that everything that you've seen so
far in the game is all to do with that
home world and that is utterly safe from
any anything from the outside unless you
decide do you want to invite people in
and I would just cancel you to be very
very careful I probably invited all
right just like my mom used to tell me
yeah like I'm told strange yes yeah I
don't follow that one very are ya know
and we're when it when two God's all out
for God's meet they meet in this place
called we called a harbor and in this
haha they can do trading they can do
sculpting mate they can introduce their
people to each other and they can go
from this hub to another hub and they'll
be doing more of that stuff so you're
always safe and homework unless you let
people in and add that round yeah you
know then those those those destructive
things could happen because I just don't
want people firstly I want people who
have never played multiplayer games
before to play this and feel secure and
so yeah and feel like they and it's just
like to about one page if you feel like
that they're in a safe environment to do
that so bizarrely what we learn from
curiosity this app that we did about
this is for folks that I noticed was a a
baby cube that you tapped on layers on
your phone and yeah crowd like millions
and thousands people got mobbed and
eventually the
individual who topped the last cube won
a prize which is a some sort of
financial stake in the game success and
then also they have the ability to to be
the first god of this sort of yeah rosea
this Chuck go Brian he's Scottish and he
gets he gets every single cent that we
make from goddess he gets a small share
of and he has that returns that right
flow six months and then that right can
do who can be challenged by another
human player I'll getting playing
goddess named and if he defeated he then
then gives up his gram someone else
takes home there is a narrative about
Peter Molyneux because he was such a
character in the games and the games
world that's often you could be and
guilty of biting off more than you can
chew at least promising them stuff that
you couldn't deliver on never you're
involved in the smaller team do you feel
like you're in more control of that or
is this just a byproduct of you being so
and enjoying games so much that you want
to bring all this stuff well I mean
there's two issues here about the
problem of a promising yes I have
definitely said things and I've said
them recently recently which have them
come to be true and there's two reasons
for that one is I'm a terrible PR / okay
is that I just you know this is what I'm
like you know I you know I I just when I
talk to good people in the press I'll
show something off and I'll say and
we're going to do this and we're going
to do that yeah we're going to do the
other and sometimes that wouldn't have
been a fully implemented feature in this
particular case all this is going live
in three weeks time so I'd have to be an
imbecile to promise something that's not
going to be in it don't mean they're in
three weeks time but you're quite right
I have / for promis'd you know a lot of
times because I get so enthusiastic
about the feature that I'm working on
and I r you know I just love what I do
so much and I love pushing the
boundaries of what i think is it should
be possible I mean
I think if the games industry was safe
all the time we wouldn't end up with
games as diverse as minecraft or
titanfall I need to be brave and you
know even something like titanfall you
know if you presented titanfall to a lot
of execs and then CEO they would have
said I'll we've have met Lori against
and not very popular yeah it's the fact
that you say no you know every met Borya
game you've seen before it to Union
everything so that bravery or that
ambition is you know we I think has come
to define what I love like this entry
the most so when we talk about goddess
this is obviously in a genre of game
that in many ways you sort of you want
the rights to and so many of the pillars
of the God game or either stuck this
worldview essentially perhaps started in
maywood populous and whatnot and then we
can talk about black and white and does
this feel safe to you or is this a
dangerous type of game you're making
because some people might think that
this is quite a peter molyneux game to
make well I mean there's dead there's
there's two things about that firstly I
didn't I didn't invent that genre I you
know I stumbled on and drop by crossfade
it was only my alcohol soaked brain that
came up with that idea and you know then
the press turn round said all this is
called a good game and it wasn't I you
know I didn't set out to do it as fer
fer this if goddess doesn't exist there
are going to be no God games left yeah
why do you think that is well because I
think firstly I think God games are
always problematic on consoles because
at the interface because by definition
their their worlds which you can
interact with in a very fun way and
bizarrely controllers of awful for free
form words you know they're very cereal
and so that meant that there hasn't been
the love and attention given to God
games for quite some time secondly there
are a few games that have come out like
farmville and cityville and
antosha plans which are being kind of
labeled or their God games yeah I don't
think they are God games because they're
not playful enough they're not more
they're not about your world there are
about this you know this very
compartmentalize world so I feel that
goddess should be a reinvention of that
game and then infusing that with the
ability that all people are playing
together is fresh and new and different
enough so that is brave when we so yes
it is it this is gonna be great later
when we asked you 20 questions after the
show we're going to try to get one word
answers it right now no it's an absolute
pleasure to talk to you bout this and
it's and it's it's incredibly
interesting another part that I'm sort
of interested in I get to some user
questions as well an apology to the two
boys over here we're just going to sit
and enjoy the game on the ipod is
totally pleasant I mean I don't know if
you guys the folks at home have been
watching it's just like the animations
you know like they sort of channel that
enjoy that you were saying the word is
that I really want is delicious and
delightful and relaxing and and the
goddess there are there is a mode we can
take you sure voyage them it is exciting
that is exciting but there I love games
more and more and I think you know my
son the same that you can kind of relax
and immerse yourself yeah and that's why
I love one of the reasons I love
minecraft so much is because you just
want to lose yourself in the game and
just making it delicious and delightful
and you know and musical and beautiful
are all the things that adds to me
caring about this world and then when I
start to put threaten start to inject
threat into that world because the world
means so much to you because you've been
relaxed than it means for much more yeah
when you're nine games now do you is
your son involved at all in any sort of
way do you consider him when you're
designing it or does he give you
pointers based on based on weiu you show
them well i mean i don't know i think
this is true of any parent but i mean a
huge motivator of any parent
is to is to make your son or daughter
Pam browser yeah I mean it's an
incredible motivator for me I mean I'm a
sucker for this I want my dog to be
proud so I mean but I you know did for
him to turn round and say I'm me to see
him playing the game beyond enjoying the
game means an incredible amount and I
don't know apparently wouldn't wouldn't
fall for that so that is that is very
instructive what he is and what a lot of
a lot of children to his ages he's 11
years old he is an incredibly harsh
critic yeah and and you know I've been
on the verge and I've had to excuse
myself from the room quite a few times
if he's gonna says you know i'll do a QA
tester yeah what's what's that bit and
you know I break down in tears always
the road to run away the year it is very
important and a lot of the games I feel
a lot of sort of in that you know but if
you excuse me to make a very loose
definition games like SimCity or like
theme marker games we were sort of your
you were the invisible hands and
effecting a world and not seeing the my
product dollars in recent years most of
these have been rehashes of older games
like we see SimCity and it's it's you
know it's largely indistinguishable from
SimCity 3000 there's something doesn't
so when you look at something like
goddess are you replicating what time
before or how is this difference to just
creating another one of these types of
games there's a feel like something
completely new I'm in my bold claim is
that there is nothing and this is gonna
sound awful go for your leading me down
there's a do you want me to save it I
don't want you to say anything you don't
want to say that there is nothing like
goddess yeah I have ever played before
there it's not like any game that has
existed before but partly because you
have ultimate freedom but you also you
have these temptations you have this
huge this thing called long motivator
which no game that I've ever been
involved with before long motivator is
retrace the hot entire history of
mankind that's a that's a long motivator
some games have attempted it I guess if
you talk
vampires and wise nations rise of
nations and more to the point of
civilization yeah and that you know but
I felt that what you're doing here is
something so delightful and so simple
you're after a while you forget your
retracing the entire history of
humankind and you're just playing the
game and just but then you realize what
Christ I've just invented paper yeah and
there was a there is a delight that so
that's the first thing the second thing
is that by making this game connect
everybody who's playing together
simultaneously at the same time we're
all doing the same thing that has never
been done before that's why we did this
crazy thing called curiosity because we
weren't even sure it was possible to do
that and then there's something
absolutely fascinating that's going to
happen and I can just see your brain
ticking away on the question that um
what we're going to do is we're going to
look at every body's decisions who are
playing goddess and we're going to
aggregate those decisions decisions such
as such a long this is a perfect example
in my GD seat or coke actually covered
this and someone came up after the talk
and she said she said I think your game
is sexist okay got us and sexist to us
and why she said well I noticed that all
the little the little people who stayed
at home and bread were women okay and I
said well yeah I think I said a black
and white as well farmers remain young
but we has these things in the game
called Commandments and one of the
commandments it comes up and the little
people ask for your decision and the
decision is should women stay at home
and work okay or should they usually
stay at home and look after the men or
they go out to work yeah and you have a
choice of whether you say no they should
go out to own up we're going to
aggregate the entire everybody's who
makes that decision all the millions of
people will play we're going to
aggregate that and say empirically yeah
okay of all these people that play this
number of them believe that women should
stay home and this number leader
and that becomes a entire commandment
for all for the low man so you're going
to answer the question if gamers are a
misogynist or not yes final answer every
of every moral question that has plagued
mankind since of birth supervisors on to
pray or just play out through it oh man
it's you're gonna get awesome Peter
Bonnie thank you so much for coming on
showing us goddess and for talking it's
an absolute pleasure